[Musique]
ma conviction profonde est celle ci
notre mission est de rendre au peuple
français
un bien précieux un bien unique qui l'a
perdu de vue depuis longtemps et qui
porte un nom tout simple
ça s'appelle l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
un jour quelqu'un est venu me voir et
m'a dit le président de la république
monsieur c'est celui à qui on confie les
clés de la maison
alors j'ai besoin de savoir qui vous
êtes j'ai trouvé que c'était une
remarque juste
je m'appelle françois bayrou j'ai 55 ans
je suis né dans un petit village des
pyrénées qui s'appelle bordères dans une
famille de paysans la vie a fait que j
habite toujours encore aujourd'hui je
suis allé à l'école communale
c'était l'école républicaine je laime
parce qu'elle offrait sa chance à tous
quel que soit leur milieu
puis ils sont venus les années lycée
j'ai passé le bac en 68 puis
l'université à bordeaux jusqu'à
l'agrégation de lettres français latin
grec
j'attache beaucoup d'importance à cette
culture classique qui est un peu de la
culture française et puis la vie vient
avec ses joies et ses peines et elle
bouleverse tous un jour mon père est
mort dans un accident du travail
j'ai décidé avec ma mère de prendre sa
suite
j'ai travailler de mes mains et c'est
une fierté pour moi
en même temps j'ai été professeur un
jeune professeur et j'ai beaucoup aimé
transmettre ce que je savais ma femme
s'appelle elisabeth nous nous sommes
mariés nous avions vingt ans il y à 35
ans aujourd'hui nous avons eu six
enfants quatre filles et deux garçons
très tôt la politique est entré dans ma
vie j'ai été un jeune député un jeune
ministre avec passion j'ai travaillé
j'ai observé j'ai eu raison je me suis
trompé j'ai appris voilà qui je suis et
maintenant ce que je veux faire je veux
rassembler les français
jamais notre pays n'a eu devant lui un
tel défi jamais il n'a connu en même
temps le chômage qui ne recule pas la
dette que nos enfants devront rembourser
les banlieues
actu ray le doute sur l'école le doute
dans les usines plus la crise du climat
plus les menaces sur les retraites plus
les fins de mois difficiles pour les
petits revenus aussi bien que pour les
classes moyennes
et tout cela avec en toile de fond
l'immense mouvement de la mondialisation
en face de tout cela la vieille guerre
politique un camp contre l'autre ce
n'est plus la question pour moi je peux
discuter et travailler avec des gens
compétents de tous bords je peux
travailler avec des gens qui ne pensent
pas exactement comme moi je le peux et
je le veux j'ai des objectifs simples
je veux que tous les enfants sachent
lire et écrire avant d'entrer en 6e
je propose qu'on n'y arrive en cinq ans
je garantirai les moyens nécessaires je
veux stopper l'augmentation de la dette
je propose qu'on le fasse en trois ans
je veux que l'on crée des emplois de
vrais emplois
je propose qu'on permette à toutes les
entreprises françaises de créer deux
emplois nouveaux
sans avoir à payer de charges pendant
cinq ans je veux sortir les rmistes de
leur isolement
je leur proposerai une activité
rémunérée dans la société dont des
associations collectivités locales je
veux rendre du pouvoir d'achat à ceux
qui travaillent et aussi à ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie
je proposerai que les petites retraites
et le minimum vieillesse soit portée à
90 % du smic en cinq ans je veux
relancer l'ascenseur social et que tout
le monde puisse avoir sa chance
d'arriver en haut
même en partant d'en bas je veux que la
france soit à l'avant-garde de la lutte
pour la biodiversité et contre le
réchauffement de la planète et je veux
réconcilier les français avec l'europe
et l'europe avec la france
ces objectifs là je ne sais pas s'ils
appartiennent à un bord ou à l'autre ce
que je sais c'est qu'ils sont urgents
je veux qu'on avance et c'est maintenant
je vous propose d'être le président qui
rassemble les français pour reconstruire
la france
ma conviction profonde est celle ci
notre mission est de rendre au peuple
français
un bien précieux un bien unique qui l'a
perdu de vue depuis longtemps et qui
porte un nom tout simple
ça s'appelle l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]